I am doing a live unboxing of the new
MacBook Pro with the touch bar this is
the 15-inch I expect this thing out -
basically it was like you know what I'm
gonna get the best of the best because
this thing is going to be my new child
this is my knife it's beautiful
it'll be really really sad I cut myself
a lot of people are extremely upset with
the lack of ports on the pro model of
MacBook I'm not gonna lie I'm definitely
a little bit upset but would the form
factor and for it to be a little bit
slimmer things have to go so nervous
it's the Space Gray it's in its little
case it's little box it's a little bed
it doesn't even have a smell usually any
time I would have a MacBook
let's go smell the first thing that we
have is a US DC charger something that I
already don't like about this is look at
this this is a very skipped cable a much
bigger brick so much waited and said
that inside of the box if you cut this
open that there is an attachment that
goes to this but I think that they're
lying there's no way they would ever do
this 100% that is not true there's
nothing under here there's our USB C
port or also known as a Thunderbolt 3
I've been quite conflicted trying to
find a good USB C or a Thunderbolt 3
travel hard drive I did get a 2 terabyte
version which is exciting especially if
you're doing a lot of video editing or
music production or photos or video
really anything that involves a lot of
space I'm upset that isn't a smell
opening it up
whoa it's turning on I'm going to touch
anything
oh good I'm touching essentially feels
like
the top of an iPhone you can have my
diagnostic I'm enabling my touch idea
touch touch touch we're gonna set up I
painted later Apple pay because you
already have a like money
app is so why do you want more of it so
here we've got this is the previous
version of the macbook they essentially
just completely ripped off this full top
part of the Maxwells really miss this SD
card slot a lot here it is hey Siri I
was wondering if maybe you could tell me
your favorite color my favorite color is
well I don't know how to say it in your
language it's sort of greenish but with
more dimensions oh I do like how thin
this is and then it looks like it goes a
little bit further to the edge it does
feel lighter a while they did even make
it a little bit shorter - this is the
15-inch
I don't really have much more or else to
say I'm gonna do a follow-up video after
this livestreams I'm gonna go shoot that
now this is it guys we've got our
Thunderbolt 3 but also USB C compatible
ports 2 on this side we also have 2 on
this side and we also have our headphone
jack something that I thought was funny
is they removed the headphone jack on
the iPhone which is fine but they put
one in the new MacBook Pros but they
also didn't give you a way to